There is a dangerous creature that could be
anywhere in the world, hiding in plain sight,
casually walking through crowded streets filled
with people.
A monster that is nearly impossible to see,
blending into its surroundings almost perfectly.
Not invisible, but unnoticeable, almost completely
undetectable.
But then, you spot a familiar outfit in a
crowd.
You now know where the creature is.
But it goes both ways, since the moment you
find it, it knows where you are.
There is now not a single place on the Earth
that you could hide where it wouldn’t find
you.
And it won’t ever stop looking.
To the staff at the Foundation this creature
is known as SCP-4885.
But you and I know him by a different name.
You may have seen his face hundreds of times,
or stared for hours at a page trying to catch
a glimpse of him.
To us, he’s Waldo.
While this might feel like a very long-winded
and silly joke, maybe even a prank that has
been inserted into the SCP archives, it is
anything but.
If you grew up any time after the elate 1980s,
then you will likely be familiar with the
Where’s Waldo?
books, but for the uninitiated, these are
a series of puzzle books created by illustrator
Martin Handford.
Each book in the Where’s Waldo?
line contains multiple double-page spreads
of colorful, crowded scenes.
The goal is for readers to spot the ever-elusive
titular character, Waldo, who is hidden among
the mass of other characters.
Waldo himself is easily recognized, thanks
to a design that has become truly iconic over
the years.
He is always depicted as wearing a red and
while striped shirt, with a bobble hat in
matching colors.
Waldo also sports jeans, circular rimmed glasses,
and sometimes a wooden walking stick.
So, with that important context out of the
way up front, what exactly is SCP-4885?
Is it the character from these children’s
books somehow brought to life?
Has the character of Waldo always been a malicious,
malevolent entity, too powerful to be contained
within his own books?
Well, not exactly.
SCP-4885 only seems to resemble the famous
children’s book character.
Whether or not he is a living manifestation
of Waldo in the real world is both unclear
and up for debate.
Examining its outward appearance, SCP-4885
does share the humanoid shape and looks to
be wearing the same recognizable clothing
of Waldo.
There are, however, two notable bodily dissimilarities
between the Waldo on the page, and the physical
form of SCP-4885.
For one, this Waldo appears to be much paler
to the one found in the book series.
More noticeably however, is the fact that,
despite wearing the same circular glasses,
SCP-4885 seems to have no eyes.
Should a person learn of SCP-4885’s current
location, Waldo will simultaneously gain an
awareness of this person.
Learning instantly of their victim’s location,
SCP-4885 will traverse any space necessary,
tracking their target down to anywhere they
might be in the world.
The creature has displayed a number of space
altering abilities, including teleportation.
SCP-4885 can also alter the state of his own
matter, allowing Waldo to phase through solid
surfaces.
No obstacle can stop his advance: not walls,
not buildings, not even his victim’s own
body.
When SCP-4885 finally reaches the person who
has learned of his location, Waldo will then
proceed to murder them in an exceptionally
excruciating manner.
Using his matter changing abilities, he will
teleport or phase himself inside his victim,
pulling himself through their body and destroying
their internal organs.
After causing catastrophic bodily damage,
SCP-4885 will then wrench their victim’s
jaw open, unhinging it with enough force to
climb his way out of their mouth, leaving
them dead, their body completely mangled.
However, this isn’t even the final stage
of Waldo’s attack.
There is a strange by-product left after a
fatal encounter with SCP-4885, a yellow liquid
that is produced as Waldo exits his victim’s
body.
When this substance comes into contact with
the deceased person’s skin, it triggers
a bizarre change.
The liquid will cause their bodies to change
after death, their skin becoming covered in
symbols.
On closer inspection is becomes clear that
these symbols are illustrations, exactly like
the ones found in the pages of Where’s Waldo?
These corpses, referred to by the Foundation
as instances of SCP-4855-1, will then start
to act in a similar manner to SCP-4885, and
anyone who sees one or learns of its location
will cause Waldo to come looking for them.
The Where’s Waldo?
scenes left on a deceased victim’s skin
cannot be washed off or otherwise removed
and the only way to undo an instance of SCP-4885-1
is to skin an infected body after death.
However, this creates a whole new problem.
If someone was to attempt this, in doing so
they would know the location of one of Waldo’s
victims.
This knowledge would mean that whomever was
trying to skin one of these bodies would themselves
become Waldo’s next target and would likely
end up just another instance of SCP-4885-1.
In other words, it would be an exercise in
futility.
Naturally, the nature of his abilities and
attack patterns makes it difficult for the
SCP Foundation to contain Waldo.
SCP-4885 cannot be harmed through the use
of firearms, or other common, conventional
weapons at the Foundation’s disposal.
You might be forgiven for thinking that making
a handful of people aware of where to find
Waldo at the same time would be a viable solution.
After all, he cannot be in multiple places
at once, so perhaps he’d be unable to kill
these individuals simultaneously.
However, SCP-4885 has shown to be able to
cope with this approach, dispatching his victims
one at a time, transforming each in turn into
Where’s Waldo?
printed corpses, before continuing to the
next would-be victim.
If the victim is nearby, Waldo will force
himself into their mouth, passing through
their body and destroying bones, organs, and
even the spinal column.
When his victim is further away, Waldo will
phase through the nearest wall and attack
them, teleporting into his target and then
climbing out of their mouth.
Waldo’s location, or that of his victims’
bodies, are considered ‘infohazards’.
Simply being aware of this information will
cause SCP-4885 to activate.
As a result of this, the staff at the SCP
Foundation are not even sure that Waldo is
actually contained at all.
In theory, SCP-4885 is being held at an undisclosed
Foundation site within a non-designated containment
chamber, since even a number on the door would
tip off what’s inside, triggering Waldo’s
abilities.
But, here’s the clincher; because nobody
can know for sure where Waldo is without him
coming for them, nobody at the Foundation
actually knows where he’s being contained,
if he’s even contained at all!
It is worth noting that, if someone receives
a vague, non-specific description of Waldo’s
whereabouts, then he will make no attempt
to seek them out.
If he is contained, and if he was to ever
breach containment, then the SCP Foundation
has an entire set of procedures in place to
ensure that no one ever finds Waldo.
First, 36 containment chambers identical to
the one SCP-4885 is supposedly held in are
connected to a self-driving vehicle.
An expendable D-Class personnel member is
placed into the vehicle and a random number
generator will select a number from one to
36.
The self-driving vehicle will then arrive
at the containment chamber chosen at random,
and the D-Class placed inside.
Within each chamber are digital monitors,
and once the D-Class is inside a chamber,
all of these monitors will display the current
location of SCP-4885.
The Foundation has a GPS tracking device implanted
within Waldo, but this information is normally
kept secret to avoid any containment breaches.
The D-Class essentially acts as bait for Waldo,
forcibly given the knowledge of his location
so that SCP-4885 will consider them a target.
As part of the next phase of containment,
Foundation staff will wait, giving Waldo enough
time to arrive in the containment chamber
and dispatch the D-Class within.
After this, all of the 36 containment chambers
are transported to random Foundation sites
in disguised trucks, so that no one is sure
where SCP-4885 ends up.
Every time SCP-4885 breaches containment,
the entire procedure has to be repeated.
The Foundation first encountered SCP-4885
a number of years ago, inside a small wooden
house, the exact location of which has since
been expunged from all the SCP Foundation’s
records.
While on an assignment to secure an entirely
different anomaly, the Foundation’s Mobile
Task Force Chi-19, also code named ‘Unrelenting
Punishment’, were the first to discover
Waldo.
The three person unit consisted of Foundation
operatives named Amelia Merrick, James Klein
and Kurt Stoll.
The trio cautiously entered the wooden house
where they were meant to investigate reports
of an anomalous, inanimate object: a pair
of black spectacles.
According to initial intelligence gathered
by the SCP Foundation, these glasses were
capable of killing anyone that tried to wear
them, leaving their body covered in pictures
like those found in a children’s book.
Sounds familiar, doesn’t it?
It is unknown if these black spectacles are
the same eyewear worn by SCP-4885, but it
doesn’t seem like too far of a leap to assume
that this may well have been the case.
Searching the ground floor, the team found
no sign of the object had been sent to recover.
As Amelia, Kurt, and James made their way
upstairs, something began making scraping
sounds beneath them, but none of them noticed.
In an abandoned bedroom on the upstairs floor
of the house, Kurt spotted a drawing on the
wall, which looked to have been made using
crayons.
He took a photo of the illustration, and this
image is still kept in the Foundation’s
database.
It appears to be a child’s drawing, depicting
SCP-4885, wearing his signature striped shirt
and hat, with empty, vacant eyes.
Next to it was scrawled one simple phrase:
“Waldo found mommy.”
Continuing their way through the house, the
team located the glasses they were looking
for in an upstairs bathroom.
However, as James bagged up the spectacles,
ready for transport back to the Foundation,
Kurt spotted another inscription on a nearby
wall, one that the team were certain hadn’t
been there when they had arrived.
James stepped in to translate it using a Foundation
standard issue translation device.
The phrase on the wall read “The basement.
The corpses from a child’s book are in the
basement.
He is there too.
Fr-.”
And we’re sure that you can already guess
what happened after that.
Immediately after reading these words, James
began to groan and clutched at his stomach,
showing signs of extreme pain.
Before Amelia or Kurt had any chance to figure
out what was happening to their squadmate,
fingers began protruding from James’ mouth.
They gripped his jaw and pulled it apart with
enough force to send his jawbone flying across
the room.
SCP-4885 climbed its way out of James’ body,
and Amelia and Kurt both opened fire on the
creature.
Waldo did not react, seemingly unphased by
the gunfire and sustaining no damage as he
approached Amelia, who would be his next victim.
Showing his fingers into her throat, Waldo
wrenched apart Amelia’s jaw, breaking it
before he clawed his way into her mouth.
As he watched in horror, Kurt made a panicked
call for help to the Foundation, but it was
too late.
Waldo had already dispatched both James and
Amelia, and now Kurt was about to pay the
same terrible price.
Ever since this incident, the Foundation believes
that they have SCP-4885 contained.
When his file was created, their researchers
created an automated algorithm, designed to
wipe away any mention of SCP-4885’s current
location or the house he was discovered in
from Foundation records.
With SCP-4885 now assumed to be contained,
that only leaves one question, the same burning
inquiry that’s been plaguing man for decades…
Where’s Waldo?
In this case, maybe it’s safer if you don't
know.
Now check out “The Lost SCP - SCP-000”
and “SCP-5049 - The Skin Salesman - Demon
Dan's Discount Homunculus Depot” for more
of the Foundation’s strangest anomalies!